this is unusual and upsetting but we got
some news we got some news during the
show that that Robin Williams has passed
away and by the time we air the we taped
these shows a few hours early and by the
time you see this now on TV I'm sure
that you'll you'll know I sorry to
anyone in our studio audience that I'm
breaking this news this is absolutely
shocking and and and horrifying and so
upsetting on every level and we're at
the end of the show and it just felt
like we needed to just acknowledge
obviously we don't know much yet we know
that this has happened and we're
absolutely stunned he's done to get this
news and I know that everybody here
we've all worked with Robin over the
years and he was an amazingly kind and
generous person and and it's got to be a
terrible time for his family and our
thoughts go out to them and as funny as
as he was he's truly one of the all-time
greats
he was even better as a person he was
even more fantastic as it's just the
loveliest sweetest one of the kindest
guys that I've ever worked with such a
just such a soft warm emotionally sweet
guy and it's a major major loss for for
everybody it's yeah like Annie said our
hearts go out to his family and yeah
there's not we're just processing this
information literally right at this you
know at this moment and and so we are
thinking of we're thinking of Robin's
family we're thinking about everybody
who he touched around the world
throughout his life and we're thinking
about Robin tonight there's really not
much else to say by the time the show
hummer back tomorrow we'll we'll know
more everyone will know more
but we're so very sorry to have to
report this to anybody who's hearing it
for the first time and we are going to
end our show now and thank all my guests
and good night and God bless Robin
Williams